فخور بما فعله هذا هو
رد عالم صيني
قال إنه ساعد في إنشاء أول
أطفال معدلين وراثيًا في العالم د.
يقول هود جين كي إنه يعدل أجنة توأم
ولد في الصين ويقول إن
حملًا آخر في مراحله الأولى الآن
مما يعني أنه يمكن أن يولد طفل ثالث معدّل وراثيًا.
للإصابة بفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية يأكلون هذه
الحماية لأن لقاح فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية غير
متوفر ولدي تجربة شخصية
مع بعض الأشخاص فيه ، حيث تلاشى
30 ٪ من شخصين مصابين بالدكتور.
الذي تلقى توبيخًا لاذعًا من
زملائه العلماء ، تم جمعهم هنا في
هونغ كونغ لحضور مؤتمر تحرير الجينوم البشري
، ويقولون إن هناك بالفعل
طرقًا للممارسة بانتظام
لمنع انتقال فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية ،
وقد أدانوا السرية
المحيطة بعمليته والتي لم
يتم التحقق منها بشكل مستقل  أو
تمت مراجعتها من قبل الزملاء وأثاروا أسئلة أخلاقية ، أدان
رئيس القمة الحائز على
جائزة نوبل ديفيد بالتيمور
أفعاله ووصفها بأنها غير مسؤولة
ولا أعتقد أنها كانت عملية شفافة
اكتشفناها فقط بعد
حدوثها و  بعد ولادة الأطفال ،
أنا شخصياً لا أعتقد أنه كان
ضروريًا من الناحية الطبية ، فقد دافعت عن
عمله هنا في القمة أمام
نفس المجموعة في عام 2015 ، حيث وضعت المبادئ التوجيهية
للتنظيم ضد زرع
الأجنة المعدلة وراثيًا دون
مزيد من البحث وبدون المزيد
بناء الإجماع أولاً ، يقول هاه إن تجربته
السريرية معلقة حاليًا ،
وتقول السلطات الصينية إنها
التحقيق والجامعة التي
يقول المضيف فيها إنه أجرى أبحاثه تقول إنهم
لا يعرفون شيئًا عن العمل الذي كان يقوم به
في مجال هونغ كونغ ألكسندرا CNN